bonjour pascal crespin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france une réaction tout
d'abord à ces images des supporters de
lille qu'en pensez vous écoutez c'est il
est sûr que si les dommages d'observer
ce type d'événement néanmoins si cela
reste ponctuel et que ce n'est pas ce ne
sont pas des comportements qui
s'installe dans la durée
ça ne devrait pas avoir un impact
négatif sur 11,4 au négatif sur la
dynamique de l'épidémie donc
donc on peut se permettre entre
guillemets au niveau populationnelle
d'avoir ce type d'écart ponctuellement
mais il faut que dès le lendemain les
gens reprennent leurs esprits et
continue de d'être vigilants vis-à-vis
du vieux parce qu'on n'a jamais vraiment
eu d'eau de de retour sur ces fêtes
sauvages qu'on a pu observer ces
derniers mois notamment cette rave party
en bretagne il n'y a pas eu de kloster
si t'as pas connu en tout cas suite à
ces rassemblements
oui alors vous avez vous avez raison a
priori ce soit sur des faits de sauvages
ou sur des fêtes plus institutionnalisé
je pense
la fête de la musique l'an dernier on
n'a pas observé de rebond de l'épidémie
ensuite pour les clusters c'est toujours
un peu compliqué de les identifier parce
que ces personnes ne se connaissent pas
tout entre elles donc reconstituer les
liens entre ces personnes et les
chiennes d'infection est quelque chose
qui qui n'est pas très facile mais donc
néanmoins on sait effectivement que le
risque de contamination extérieure est
relativement faible mais si on reproduit
les conditions de l'intérieur en
extérieur avec cette promiscuité et
l'absence totale de gestes barrières et
bien on peut avoir des contaminations et
est donc avoir des cas d'infection qui
aurait pu être évitée ça devient plus
problématique en intérieur il ya un
variant dits préoccupants à bordeaux ce
week-end en gironde cluster de 50
personnes
faut-il s'en inquiéter alors tout ce qui
concerne les variants est pensé et
potentiellement un sujet d'inquiétude si
vous regardez en angleterre aujourd'hui
dans certaines régions d'angleterre le
variant indien par exemple a pris le pas
sur le variant anglais le variant que
qui a été observé à bordeaux est
invariante qui est plus proche du
variant angles et que du variant indien
mais qui a notamment une mutation du var
yann piat qui potentiellement le rend
plus transmissible et donc il faut
absolument lutter contre l'installation
de ce type de variants il est d'autant
plus facile de lutter contre leur
installation si le niveau de circulation
générale et bas parce que c'est avec
toutes les mesures de contact racing
dont d'identification des cas de
remontée des chaînes de transmission que
l'on peut étouffer ce type de cas
groupés et donc
donc il faut continuer les efforts et
les haies et faire en sorte que le virus
ce traditionnel afin que l'occurrence le
le variant en anglais ces reculs à un
niveau le plus bas possible
c'est aussi nous permet de dégager des
ressources pour lutter contre
l'installation de variants plus
problématique encore que le varia
anglais vous dites qu'il est qu'il est
au tout plus en plus transmissible que
le variant indien est il plus virulent
est ce qu ils provoquent des formes plus
grave c'est surtout ça la question
alors non je dis que le vario indien et
plus a priori plus transmissible que le
variant angles et le variant qui a été
observé à bordeaux à une mutation en
particulier qui est proche de celle du
variant indien mais c'est difficile à
dire à ce stade et surtout sur très peu
de cas s'il est plus transmissible que
le variant anglais est encore plus
difficile à dire s'il est plus sévère
que le variant angles et on a
malheureusement besoin d'avoir un
certain
un grand nombre de cas pour pouvoir
faire entre guillemets des statistiques
et mieux connaître les caractéristiques
de ces variants remet donc langer dans
le doute c'est d'étouffer le plus
rapidement possible la circulation de ce
variant et donc ne donne pas avoir
l'occasion de se rendre compte si les
plus transmissible plus sévère ou pas
alors pour l'étouffer il va falloir
s'isoler on a vu ces personnes se faire
tester une campagne de vaccination aussi
ciblé a été décrétée pour pour mercredi
est ce que la vaccination peut endiguer
un cluster alors qu'on sait que ça
protège pas forcément contre la
contamination
alors ça dépend de quel vaccination vous
parlez en l'occurrence la vaccination
qui est utilisé dans ce genre de
situation sont les vaccins arn messager
qui eux ont un impact très fort contre
la transmission elle aussi avec une
efficacité de l'ordre de 80 cents ce qui
est très bon donc la vaccination peut
tout à fait être une réponse adaptée
pour étouffer ce type de gloucester
néanmoins elle ne peut pas être la seule
réponse parce que le temps d'être enfin
d'être immunisé suite à une vaccination
est relativement important il faut au
moins dix jours après la première dose
pour commencer à avoir un certain niveau
d'efficacité et contre les nouveaux
variants keep variant indien par exemple
il faut malheureusement attendre deux
doses donc donc c'est forcément quelque
chose d'un peu relativement peu réactif
donc effectivement c'est les stades et
les stratégies de lutte ester tracé
isolé qui vont être les plus efficaces
dans ces moments là et donc il faut bien
que la population réagisse de façon très
réactive vis-à-vis de cette lutte contre
les transmissions se fasse des speed des
pistes et s'isole s'ils sont infectés et
une limite en tout cas là
leur contact en attendant de pouvoir
être dépistés
elle est de savoir s'ils sont positifs
de la résurgence des variants indien
dans certaines villes au royaume uni à
la france a placé le royaume uni sous
surveillance on sait pas trop ce que ça
veut dire puisque l'allemagne est là à
décréter des zones de mutation des
variants c'est-à-dire qu'elles imposent
une quarantaine justement à la grande
bretagne à cause de ces variants est ce
que la france devrait faire la même
chose alors il est clair que
l'angleterre malheureusement pour pour
les anglais perdu là cette première
bataille visant à empêcher
l'installation du paria lundi sur 60
territoire ce n'est pas encore notre
qu'un pardon
et pourtant les vacciner mais pas
forcément à à la rn messahel et les
vaccinés en grande partie avec le vaccin
astrazeneca qui malheureusement est
moins efficace avec tout un contre ces
nouveaux variants où on a 60 %
d'efficacité après deux doses
et puis malheureusement pour eux il faut
vraiment cette deuxième dose dans la
deuxième dose d'astrazeneca arrive très
tardivement jusqu'à 12 ou 16 semaines
après la la première dose
ce qui fait que relativement peu
d'anglais sont totalement vacciner ce
qui explique peut-être aussi en partie
le fait que le variant indiens aient pu
s'installer sur le territoire donc
effectivement il faut être très vigilant
vis-à-vis de l'importation de ces
variants et puis en particulier de ce
variant indien sur notre territoire et
donc imposer les quarantaines des tests
les tests négatifs à l'entrée sur le
territoire français semblent
effectivement une bonne chose
et parce qu'il va vraiment falloir
éviter cette installation enfin cette
importation puis cette installation de
ce variant indien et d'autres variantes
potentiel merci beaucoup parce qu'elle
crée fait pour toutes ses explications
ce matin dans la matinale rt france